let's see gentlemen it gives me great
pleasure to introduce Pedro almodóvar
good afternoon you know the title of
this lecture is telling stories and I
will try to read directly in English so
wish me good luck you know always put
this is something that I see I suppose
that this is part of being a screen
writer
I always put titles of everything that I
do at least that I write well I've
always perceived of cinema the fields
I've made as a representation of life
not a slight if sell yourself but as its
representation perhaps for that reason
the scripts are written until now have
been aspired by reality reality in all
its manifestations what I hear what I
see or experience in my own life the
fields that affect me the most atrocious
events that have read about in the
newspaper or the more surprising and
moving ones family life friends solitude
Beauty the failures and the pleasure
that one finds throughout life and in
the origin of fiction I have always been
fascinated by creation in itself and by
the interaction between the process of
creation and its creator new items in
the newspaper saturator and
extraordinary incidents are usually a
great source of inspiration for example
I read in a newspaper that in New York a
woman in coma for nine years became
pregnant and gave birth to a child a few
days later they discovered that the
culprit was an oddly in the clinic
beyond the moral judgment were struck
most was that a body who its science
have defined that clinically death that
is determined by the brain could and
gender a new life that extraordinary
fact inspire me to make the first note
on top to her the story of a perfect
nurse who looks after a young women in
common with whom he ends up falling in
love but I'm not inspired only by
extraordinary facts at times inspiration
comes from everybody everyday situations
it's worse if I give you an another
example I was in a bar having a coffee
it was time for the news program and the
television was on the female newsreader
talked about a murder a man had been
found death it suddenly occurred me that
I'd like the newsreader to continue
saying and I know who killed him and I'm
going to tell you the idea amuse me
enough is so as to make a few notes I
will hone a developed and develop the
situation the situation that had just
occurred to me and then I thought it was
a good idea for a short film after a few
days I've read the manual story again
and I found it interesting I was
intrigued by someone could do what the
newsreader did and fascinated about the
idea of a confession or such caliber
taking place right in the middle of a
news program I immediately wanted to
write I mean to know the reason why the
newsreader killed someone and then
confessed it and also what happen to her
after the public confession but to
satisfied my curiosity I have to write
everything that happened before the
television program and what happened
what happened afterwards reality
provides you with the first lines of the
story but the writer
if he is sufficiently curious must write
the rest to know what happens in such an
everyday situation as having a coffee in
a bar while television was so in a news
program I found the seed of high heels
it can also happen that what is pyre
the first idea disappears while this
this the film is being developed I mean
the script is being developed at times
the inspiration the starting point of a
narrative is an excuse that leads you to
a story that you couldn't imagine before
and the origin of the story what drove
you to write to write it disappears
along the way chance is an essential
part of writing as our tenacity and
curiosity without of course talent
writing a script is always an adventure
I always have the impression that I'm
not the owner of the story I am writing
but rather the story chooses me some way
of manifestation itself I act as a
medium the author's relationship at
least in my case
with the origin of the story and its
development is always mysterious and
unpredictable I am not the one who
decides it at least until a first draft
received that is where the most
important work in writing begins
correcting the material time and again
writing a script is rewriting it
continuously until it's done for the
sound mixes when I say that inspiration
always comes from reality I include
myself as part of reality generally
inspiration has its origin in a serial
reality about a film a conversation
something after all so on but
inspiration can also come from inside
oneself we are still in the realm of
reality
but in this case the reality is inside
you inside your heart on your memory is
an intimate reality that doesn't always
have to be confessional because fiction
always appears crouching in the first
ideas reading of them and dominating
this reality
from a certain level of writing I have
fallen back on on certain elements on
more than one occasion in order to write
my scripts my mother and my side I will
submit scene stories or texts that I
have written before and that find a
place years later in some of my stories
cinema films both as a potato and
director and the memory of a love cut
short when it was still alive and beaten
motherhood is a recurrent element in my
filmography what have I done to deserve
these high heels ball bear the flower of
my secret all about my mother and pain
and glory and now in Spanish nobody sent
me in francium I studied others to see
you la candelaria completo theme
containers soup on go Kara Mustafa lo
que record ABBA he delivered a dementing
Laurel a game on drink on Oscar oh the
me memoriam
per episode LTM putting pull Sameera
atras do Madonna to run supporters
locations mother earth this take a bath
earth in a land I knew me know a theater
set in timonium the NIA mu Saprissa
probably important Astoria's salami da
bahia Volante muna stimula dope or me
presented the horn or Eleni o que de
Bourgh opponent russia an mo lova many
famous de la tradición Espanola el pasad
además estaba con Tama nada por la dick
Tallulah DeFranco yo yo la hora con
sentiment a mi memoria como si nunca a
resist evo toda la película screamin
Ibrahim en la regla de lo Sesenta desde
pepper Lucy bomb hasta en lasa desde la
nación de La Roquette ahora en como si
madrid la ciudad only Maria in las
personas de los que debería
Ramos nacido and mil novecientos attend
ACA después de la muerte de little solo
me da Bahia delante Nocenti la necesidad
de madera trois hasta los angeles mean
desta me Dada retrospect Eva so here on
las películas moist indos llama la
educación evil were lamonica caffeine
draconian lo peor them in fancy em no
recuerdo smashes kudos jamie rellis ian
con las gorras Silesia knows if
Francisca knows condos case to the
embassy urato the mother involvement a
spontaneous
recupera lemuria the neutral party the
mean fan Thea click on el tiempo Sevilla
convert IDO en el Reverso delicacy on
grassy video skuas Murphy no army
premiering fancier who run hasta las
ocho años es primero trials era de
mujeres in Madrid Athena's saponin me
better era for mafune como persona so no
sign of cincuenta us pestle muchas de
vionnet Sabha for senado por la vida de
las mujeres que me rodea van mujeres
fuertes lucha Dora's Allegra's a just
beneath Iran la vida en la fiction
I'm Campbell burner in the uni know the
story a service Alaska mercifulness
que us could Java a las bussiness in los
patios bands ellos Astoria's de Muertos
aparecido
nebula Fiona CSS roses or quando a
company AMA mi madre alle Barla ropal
REO con otras mujeres asuno they were
required as mass releases them in FAFSA
her elemental form apart they the
Misiones son lost estas history and
different the say pocus de mi vida é que
Guardado and forma the NOTAM reflection
personal relative Corrado oh he on in a
Collado
when they are gonna blow in a bleak
anaemia a per se la set-piece element a
man wanting la nación de una película mu
de que el in from a Dominique no a beast
Randolph imitator
una película Kelly appear to rubato ek
después de cuenta
Olivia Olivia la hora in coma
alakay qui Dinello sweetened as I said
PCM blanco y Negro que podría fulfil our
demo Dalton amo pero con arroz en yo UT
listo para oculist our Loco
in La Veta under hospital in rabbinic no
Alicia the horn in coma during the last
three too damn good hobby amputee fellow
con el Dulce she kobato interpreted oh
poor Xavier camera sorry I can algún
momentum Eva Bueller al Holland coma
porque si la da original comedy help in
CP o your bein layin on the TV Athena
Mohan coma it not spittle de Nova your K
dispersed the granules in air temp are
be above aloof from the way I must focus
DSS curio tellurium you lado UN Camaro
converting alchemy hero and infirm arrow
yunkai sevilla des del principio ke
become a terran actor criminal me they
better come on a rod or éramos travel
personaje in toda su monedas see us
diffic are no pero SP condo camara boom
consejo paris clitoris after esprit de
torres nunca hooligans on personaje
al Kelly Davis Darby de acción Seco
bottom personal men team Cena
psychopathy empathy Thark Kannan
personaje no continuous QB end of
Astoria
Yaya via empathy fado collie personaje
de venir no an ephemeral y como si
separate era una meager real nokia
barely be Orlando a second coma
algo dentro de meme say rebel avec entre
la idea de nostril Sistina
inspected or sin embargo comunidad or de
Beatriz mental hospital or local coroner
Madhavi under hospital in training for
Marilyn firma entonces el correo top our
last inna de la nación Connaughton
Eruzione otra vez de la cual el hospital
intend area lo que realmente estaba
corriendo en revenues no in enfermo few
SE como se murio poner el amante men
want a como top Avera callamezzo riviera
loco Carrillo nasalization esta pieza
gelatinous [ __ ] en forma de primera
Oradour una no cement al-razi de la rosa
la mañana
Parvati se parte de este Guillen prairie
o yo introduce an inhalation
they are Laconia nunca querido cases
clear a mirror of here mi vida star of
the hava element you Nepali
just chaos harem Tommy rhythm this is
different the setup asked me Familia my
pious Mis Amore's Mira la vie on connect
a few on a standard trust de los
personaje de las Primera's been to
moleculus a novelty mom the dollar
Gloria we present here the lanty there
are there are cameras a massive event a
mass intima in esta el tema art
identification Camilla sort of
ridiculous para por la la referee via
will put her on Easter soil yo mismo
documentary on TV affair Paredes raha
Antonio and Dara's same controvert
dental miss and Ranas in memoriam any
solid othe and mis propios Dolores EMS
be ellos verrano's just earlier Sumerian
mythology as in lapis Tina mm Antonia ba
Halawa in Mobile and Tim pocket resist
Erin miss pramanas evil Ria's well he'll
be después a shocker tiempo Marian uber
alles Panda y toda la musculature
Assyria El Dorado después de l'opéra
film came in mobile is so limited
Lombard Ellis pan de el momento a splash
and Taryn del día del tiempo para maana
Thea superhero en el agua bajo el agua
por Liang Ravi death toll attention
muscular
the Sabathia the special repetir sturdy
12 durante semanas man de alguien que me
quiera una foto a necesito Funes
concerned ova Halawa colored Rafa
sustained Eidos
float Ando chaos a ver como eres I'm
ahem la foto memory few suficiente meant
a mystery osa is o hasta la it's in
severe chaos accompany via an onion
empathy as Camila
el agua de pastino like a tooth in hora
de bajo la was in pretty near los ojos
tirado's Metra's Porto out rock-oriented
niki de el río de madre y nuestra Cena's
even Al Abbar para me era una verdadera
fiesta el dolor illa Gloria ya que
Dobbin establecido en estas dos primero
sequences
pero Jonah really totally ask reveal
onion energy mean Timmy dothis to era
tan present / same sis cleveo luminaire
and electro sobre me
if you karate grunt alors not pro super
sannyas tendrá que hablar the mean timid
ah've in Tolleson turistas they promote
Eon universe wanna bleep you know Rosa
después de un momento de rue de it's a
lot as well affair Quan described OHP
rather and are really dothis Terrier met
Clara leadeth co-efficient tomar
convience here the me mismo me adore me
dharmic con la sufficiently stunt yeah
como para escribir not a nearly
impression the serve girl personaje de
antonio and eras see no alguien que
pareció mutrah mean yeah kyun podría
hacer con mi mundo connects live only on
no importa call selespeed Afyon a
momento que la fiction dominant relative
ego importante scale resultado ser Boros
Cemal como fiction on kcal Ahad Odelle
Aurelio el agua la Korean deli key de
areia / a Fiddler's del principio common
element okay the finial on our oven
loudest intercept occurs kappa resident
alien debian flu ear come off rougaille
agua they won't do it protagonist I just
have a theorem and only return the cname
this isn't a news crew friend the
various Valencia's if we make a sea ice
lava in su casa de première until idea
they can normally refer película por que
no está en condiciones physicals a
fellow Salvador Mayo noon Caesarea
detenido a sentences a vivid una vida
splash IVA energy he knows a tanto
professional como into momentum in the
repenting Arbor a fee on the spell de
hunt out of problemas physicals love
Leegin
resonances nunca vino tiempo para pensar
en sí mismo simply be open dientes de
película es trivia trod abba
Mon Taba Oprah bossa nova esos eran los
cuatro C close temporalis de su
existential su primera Furano
soir Tonio issue invierno siempre
esteban marcado's por la película que
tenía en Romano's esta situación de
Islam en toe day in accion en la que
vivir por primera vez la impulses a mere
are a Fiat rus' con boca la memoria de
su infancia
su vida como hone adult o en el Modelo
Sesenta la importancia
named telegram pantalla en su vida in
recuerdo de morte to walk a quarter
cuando él estaba vivo en recuerdo agree
dulce de los últimos onions de su madre
en este para Nava panorama argument on
los tres textos de los que le gusta bon
perfectamente al relati Samba door intra
rien contacto con doctor con el Katrina
años antes area trabajado ya bein a
Collado playin da same Parabolica meant
a stack or representa in Teatro della
TiVo El mono logo la adición
Kuya or a Salvador EKU abs credo a los
años momento tambien poodle Cooper are
El Rey lot o del primer the sale he have
clickers hello alla infancia the
salvador este an EXO not beluga hasta el
último momento indirect a final del
espíritu de leon durante la escritura yo
Korea's Alvaro Salvador por que era como
salvar a mi mismo pero no podía force
are low BB unas semanas de insert the
hombre
hasta que en contra la solución cuando
Ella consulted el raviolo home Mercedes
was his tenth Leominster limiter
fielder's position the art a popular
animal let me the fuel moisture una
querella panino centavo and when pat you
interieur
throw the other in of Thetas the end of
libro and S&E newest and prop no
Salvador que recuerda and momento and
kinghorn Alba Neil
the Hollis Dana después syllabus mundo
con el agua de una Palin gana survival
requires a lot to bassoon
del Nino until de primera pollution
Delta se esta required imagine a club a
para salvar a solid or después de la
consulta radio locum es pasa por la
Galleria de Arte control occur Ella
sequent años después la querella del
vino rodeado dem isettas yaga manos de
su decided REO y por primera vez en
mucho tiempo Salvador siente la
necesidad aku siente de cantar historia
con el era su casa Salathe realmente
Sorel ordinal or MPF escribir la lo
primero el título el primer deseo la
necesidad de cantar historia me
proportion
el mejor modo de salvar a my proton esta
casa el mismo que el rey de la película
de infancia todo lo que estas memento
and Ori Gloria LS petted or a credo
Kaylin flashbacks shown in Raleigh de la
película que Salvador esta Redondo por
que la verdadera dependency adel person
ahem
no son las drogas civil sin segi Latino
películas que con dar una historia que
contar que le pasa por el retiro una
historia que letras port area el lugar
sindelle or el territorio de la vie en
las Astoria's Asuna Rivera's era mejor
final capo di Mariner para solid origami
I wanted to start actually with just by
making a point rather than asking a
question yes because it's it's so clear
through Pedro's
talk and his career 21 films I think
when when people write screenplays in in
the UK generally in order to find a
connection to the audience they think
about genre so what are they going to
write is it going to be a period film is
it a you know biopic is it something for
an adaptation is it a comedy is it
horror they start with a genre and then
somehow I think feel the responsibility
to stick to the dictates of that genre
all the way through and I think I think
Pedro's way is so interesting the idea
that all you're concerned about as you
write is what the director in his case
obviously it's himself is going to be
able to make it of interest to the
audience he's thinking about the
audience all the time um no I don't
think about it okay
it just means that I guess might affect
it I mean I I love the audience and I'm
hilarious a moment when I only
about the audience but that moment is
when I finish the movie when I mean a
week before they opening then you know
shaking just thinking about the audience
but never never before I mean I am when
I'm writing I'm the more free person I
mean even I'm more free than in my real
life I'm completely free and don't think
in anything but the story and as I said
I feel usually as a median of the story
and it's the story who asked me to do
something or and something the story
asked me to write something the right
then I don't want but I mean but you
know what the story demands it very
clearly so I never did I mean that this
20:21 movie that I did because also the
the audience I don't know how is the
audience I don't know what phase they
have is something a Morpho KK Orinoco no
Streelman event Radames same premise or
Brenda la reacción de la alianza yo creo
que inclusive quando and electorial
street or piensan demasiado in the real
via sake evoke an is a year on surprises
I'm going to disagree with your own work
because I think if you look at just to
name some of your early films women on
the verge of a nervous breakdown tie me
up tie me down high heels all about my
mother talk to her if you look at I
would say people at film school should
look at and study the first five minutes
of each of those films really every
single moment of those first five
minutes is of enormous interest the
graphics the music the sound it's it's
so clear to me that you are a master at
holding the audience's attention and
that's a critical five minutes at the
beginning of a movie if people
lost then they turn away yeah you know
I'm I mean always I am I try to be very
clear to the audience in this in this
case yes I think about the audience and
I try I mean during the fight the first
five minutes to tell what will be the
story about so like commodity release
Pettifer no Ramaswami we're in esta
Torino and prophecy NSS until o mean
tension is color with mass and Kalevala
ser absolutely transparent a corner
respectable another example that is from
the from talked to her the idea that the
the other chap who's not the one in the
in the who's not the nurse his
relationship was with a female
bullfighter such an unusual choice of
role I think and and yet it pays off
brilliantly at one moment when we see
her fighting a bull and with this
extraordinary
Alberto Iglesias song you know and it
just seems to me as though you are
thinking all the time about the moments
and how they're connecting to to you
probably you know I think of it as
thinking of the audience but that's just
a it's a sequence that you could not
have had if she hadn't been a
bullfighter obviously but it's a it's
just an extraordinary eat so it feels to
me as though what you do is you find
extraordinary moments and that are going
to connect to you and to the audience
whether they're dramatic or beautiful or
they remind us of our childhood all the
time you are finding you feel the
responsibility to find those things I
think you probably think of them as for
yourself not for the audience yeah I
don't know he's wonderful you know when
that connection that happens and I mean
thinking about for a simple pain and
glory and I listen many people in
telling me
that they don't see my mother when they
down and the old mother appears that all
they see there our mother and of course
I was thinking about I love that it was
cut in a moment that it was still alive
but the audience is not thinking about
my biography and my love affairs in the
past but because this is a kind of
experience that I hope that almost
everyone has in their life yes to love
someone and sometimes that you have to
cut and so this is I mean this is a kind
of miracle with that when that happens
but this is this is how it is and but
what you need is to be sincere when you
are telling this kind of story
then everyone feel can feel identified
with that and I mean in the case of talk
to her
the reason that I that I chooses a
bullfighter a female bullfighter it was
because him I wanted a a profession very
close to death and the I didn't want a
killer so you know I mean I cannot say
that but you know in Spain I mean in the
Spanish in the bullfighter you call it
Matador which is exactly killer so I
wanted someone very close to that
experience and also because just to be
in common is I mean for for the science
it's just a death yes it is a physical
see that death of the brain and so it
was because of that and but it says but
you know I'm really thinking about for
example about England
I'm always overwhelming that my movies
works worked so well here because really
our culture are very different and then
you know I mean at the beginning I I
always thought to be to upgrade news for
the
for the British audience is wonderful
just to mean to feel this kind of
reciprocity with with the British
audience you know I never try even in my
beginning that I have a reputation of
being like the Spanish and Fanta really
I never try or wanted to outrage anyone
come on it was my way of telling the
story it was my my way of watching the
world around me and so I respect when I
was outrageous but I didn't try when are
in a sense for example that Madonna
tried to be all the time at the edges
that is what it was not my point
I wish we could go on for the next hour
but apparently we can't so what a
privilege it's been a pleasure thank you
thank you what do you join me in
thanking
[Applause]
[Music]
you